So I have this program called
holding cell fourth program.
Its components is the future arm program.
And I was speaking to consider their
lives deeply and to develop a vision and a
strategy.
And it's not easy to have someone
who hasn't been encouraged that say,
my vision has been on practice.
Avid.
People say,
well,
I don't know what I should be doing.
It's like,
well,
you know,
some things you shouldn't be doing.
So that's a good start.
I do need them.
And it was practical planner.
If you don't know what to do,
you would start by stopping doing all
the stupid things that you're doing that
you know are stupid.
And that's a good start if it
starts to clear your vision,
right?
So if you,
if you don't know what to do,
but you do know that you're doing
things that you're ashamed of,
something you regret,
you could start by just
eliminated in one by one and
slowly to the best of your ability.
And then there's your,
so that journey of matter is
starting to become disciplined.
The false of ethical rules
on some set of ethical rules.
And with any luck,
it can follow a set of
ethical rules long enough,
then you'll get disciplines enough.
So you'll start to have a clear vision
and then you might be able to see the way
forward.
Or you might see a way more important
for intended rather than merely what you
should avoid.
So that's a good initial practical issue.
It's well,
because everyone knows you know perfectly
well that there are things you would
do even,
you know you shouldn't do,
but you don't.
Stall
started stopping
because of the natural part of this
idea about putting your house in perfect
order before you criticize the world.
Because there's a question
that's always open and that's,
suppose this is the question,
so to speak.
They'd gone placed in front of cake.
It's like,
well,
how do you know the world?
Would we interpret places you
weren't sent to Richard thing?
Maybe it wouldn't be.
And I don't mean might say,
well that's pretty challenging,
I'm sure.
Would you say to people who has a parent
who's dying of Alzheimer's disease,
for example,
like wasn't gonna hit their act
together and he's going to fix that.
It's like it made it a hell of a lot
better than it wouldn't be otherwise.
I can tell you that.
And that's something because it's bad
enough to have someone who's dead and you
and your family without having an
incredible amount of unnecessary pathology
gathering around that and make something
that could be merely tragic into
something that's outlined.
Hell No.
It happens to people all the time.
And so even if it's not
the perfect solution,
the best solution that you have,
and then the next part of that is when
I suggested to people that they do the
future authoring program and they're,
they're leery about doing it.
I asked them to do it back because a
bad plan is way better than no plan.
Because if you didn't come into town,
they didn't learn why
you should that plan.
Exactly.
Not Hypothetically,
but exactly in the world.
And then in the news,
that information above her
failure to retool a better clap.
And so the English like manufacture,
you're tracking the destination,
it's moving,
there's some kind of ideal
and your vision is blurry.
You don't know where to look.
So you're going to go this way
and then you can go that way.
We can go this way.
But if you keep doing that big,
the deviations from the right path
agreed going to decrease his time and
eventually you'll be walking
forward in an efficient manner.
And you might have to take all sorts
of errors before you manage that.
But I've watched people long enough in
my clinical practice to know that waiting
for Kudos and very bad idea and
not going up as a very bad idea.
It's like implement the
best plan and half a half
and learn from and that works and you
get sharper at making your planets.
And then the other thing that we do
with the future authoring program,
the school,
we ask people,
well,
maybe you can't decide what your
passion or your calling should be,
but it's a pretty cool question.
But you like ask yourself
some questions like,
well,
is there something you could do to
improve your intimate relationship?
One thing,
is there a way that you can
improve your friendships?
Is there something you could do at your
job that would make it better than it is
now?
Even if it's something incremental,
could you do something more productive
and meaningful with your time outside of
work?
Could you be slightly better at
handling temptations that come your way?
Could you take care of herself somewhat
better mentally and physically?
And you know the answer to all
of those questions is jeopardy.
Yes.
And then you can even ask
himself a simpler question,
which would be well into something that
you could do that would make one post
things better.
Is there also something
that you would have to,
and you can ask yourself that instead
of telling yourself that you should,
which is the same thing,
might say,
well I would like my
marriage and ask yourself,
well how can my marriage be better?
And you'll get a bunch of
answers and most of you in place,
because if you really ask
yourself the question like that,
the part of our agreements and magic and
who's looking for new masters will tell
you.
And then we'll tell you a bunch
of things you don't want to hear.
I load them with the things you already
know and some of them will be thinks
that there's just no gam you,
even though you know that you should,
but some subset of those might be things
that you should do that by your own
definition that you actually would
we,
is there a step in the right direction?
So eight would ever step
in the right direction.
You're willing to take day by day and
that's incremental progress and it'll
little spire awkward.
It does fire up well.
There's a stage of the New Testament,
which actually happens
to be a true statement,
which is to those who have
everything more will be given.
And it's a,
it's a reflection of underlying
phenomenon that looks like phenomenon.
It looks like a natural law,
which means that as things
start to recruit to you,
the rigging average,
they move further accrue will increase.
That's a natural law school.
Price's law sometimes or deport for Credo,
it's reflective and creative distribution.
So there's a chapter 12 rules for
life called don't compare yourself.
Compare yourself to
where you were yesterday,
not to someone else's today.
And it's an injunction for
incremental improvement.
If you don't know where
to go in your life,
well think about where you are
and see if today could make,
where do you are somewhat better on some
dimension so that when you go to bed at
night,
you're not as rich as you were
when you woke up in the morning.
And so if you do that in the two years,
you know,
one thing a day,
just a small thing,
something you could actually
do that you would do,
then your life will be way headed.
And at the end of that,
you might have enough clarity of mind to
start to understand where you would go
if things worked out
from across the world.